hallo leute jetzt wieder eure x banner
und willkommen zu einem neuen video
ich weiß nicht ganz was ich mir bei der
frisur gedacht habe aber hey es ist
irgendwie packen zu meinem hemd kann das
teil
ich bin ganz aufgeregt wegen dem
heutigen video denn ich war in london
und habe mir dort das theaterstück von
harry potter angeschaut ich weiß das
social media wie ihr euch wahrscheinlich
schon damit rotgesperrt zu gefährt tod
zu gespannt aber guckt hier 450 die
tickets als beweisstück weißt du gar ich
mal wirklich da und es gab zwei
vorstellungen
das heißt an zwei abenden jeweils um
19.30 und es ging ganz vor eineinhalb
stunden
und ja wurde auf zwei tage aufgeteilt
und was noch nicht sagen also es war
großartig also ohne witz ist es einfach
nur mega gut gewesen wie das auf die
bühne gekriegt haben recht ich habe mir
es am anfang nicht vorstellen können wie
sie quasi etwas was für ihn war und
natürlich ein buch aber was den film war
und jetzt auf die bühne zu bringen und
beim theater und er so dasitzt nicht das
größte bühnenbilder es nicht wenn
schlafzimmer ab dargestellt wird dann
stehen wir zum beispiel nur zwei betten
und dann ist es halt das schlafzimmer
und ja aber nach fünf minuten waffen
würden in der story und dem was sie
gespielt haben das super cup also ich
war einfach nur gut für die leute die
vielleicht beste stück noch angucken
tickets haben wollte ich brauch ist
richtig bombel und für die die leider
kein ticket haben und mit uns vielleicht
auch gar nicht anschauen wollen
ja wir verpasst was ich würde mal nach
ticket ausschau halten ich glaube bis
2018 ist es geben aber ich glaube man
kriegt immer mal wieder titel her ich
habe eine andere kneipe getroffen
an der schlange zur toilette wir haben
uns unterhalten dann recht schnell ob
von der für beide aus deutschland kommt
und er hat mir erzählt dass sie gerade
mit ihrer freundin auf brasilien
da ist und wie um acht uhr morgens sich
an die platten
sie sind zum theater gegangen und haben
acht uhr morgens befragt ob es tickets
gibt die zurückgegeben wurden und werden
glück wir haben glaube ich 100 pfund pro
vorstellungen pro person bezahlt was
extrem viele ich glaube diese gefahren
was haben sie gekostet
frühstück 65 freundlich zu wenig ich
glaube 65 grund sind 80 eur 106 das war
es wert muss wirklich sagen es war es
wert
jeder will dass fans denn für diese
reise aufgegeben habe habe ich gern
ausgegeben denn es war einfach nur mega
cool und natürlich haben wir nicht nur
das theaterstück angeguckt sondern waren
auch ein bisschen shoppen arbeit muss
sagen wir haben nicht wirklich
kleidungen wo geshoppt weil die meisten
leben die man in london findet findet
man mittlerweile auch in deutschland als
in berlin gibt alle leben gehe ich da
gesehen hat und vererbung gefährden
harry potter bezogen und flüssigkeiten
ja mein leben
[Musik]
darling p
ich habe nämlich ein souvenir habe ich
mir mitgegeben lassen ein wenig gekauft
was wertvolles und zwar diese täter
ich zeige euch nochmal richtig wenn sie
ausgeheilt ist wenn jetzt die bedeutung
hinter der tafel wissen wollt dann sage
ich euch ich war in london fand passend
cool und auf jeden fall für diese reise
gab es gehen blickt also die narbe von
harry potter fan von klein
vielleicht habt ihr das auch wo ich für
eine kleine tour findet mal so ich mag
ist groß ich mag meine arm wolle sich
mag man leute ihres haben oder oder bei
den ich gegangen bewegt bin ich cool
aber dafür ein lob an video ist mutig
ist definitiv auch was esse ich habe
auch tierischen hunger und zwar habe ich
ganz tolle sachen gekauft shorttrack
weingummi typischen kekse in england zum
thema gibt crunchy riegel
der ist so geil noch von riegel von
dieser englischen schoko für marchetti
und ich war in so einem süßigkeiten
laden den es in deutschland also ich
kenne das auch als gibt's schon mal in
amerika gesehen ich war noch nie in
amerika gibt durch film und blogs
gewinnmöglichkeiten leben wie vor zu
teilen wie es aussehen und irgendwie ja
sowieso ein kleines kinderparadies auf
ihren touren laden war dass auch ich hab
in deutschland noch nie so einen kleinen
laden gewesen aber da gab es auf jeden
fall meine lieblings fähigkeit in einer
schlange zusammengebaut mit gummi lecker
für unglaubliche 4 und eine kleine
packung ländliche geschmacksrichtung hin
dann haben wir noch keine flake
schokolade gekauft
ein stade de france ich wollte sagen die
wird so ineinander gelegt und dann nicht
so fest sondern ganz krümelig was
eigentlich total scheiße ist wenn man
sich nicht begangen möchte aber wie es
auch dabei gewesen und jetzt fange mal
an zu essen
ich habe vom shop.de gelten aber ich
hatte vorher probiert dann klopft mir
jetzt das erste mal gekauft und es ist
super lecker
eigenes sagen dass besteht also short
break besteht ja einfach mal butter und
zucker und ich tatsächlich nur
butterkeks ich bin so englisch
das war das absolute paradis franken auf
touren
double decker double decker
dann habe ich schon was begehrten der
toben wenn lukas und unten crunch durch
einfach wie ein dicker marshmallow mit
immerhin neuer vorsetzen
ich hatte keine neue vorsätze neue
vorsätze sind echte windows meiner
meinung nach also ganz ehrlich wenn du
dich verändern willst kannst du jeden
tag machen und da ändert nichts daran
dass die jahreszeitlich ändert
vielleicht braucht manche dieser
motivation des neuen jahres schlägt
jeden morgen wenn du aufstehst kannst du
dein leben komplett umkrempeln
vielleicht nicht mittags mit einfluss
man schon so ein bisschen erschöpft aber
morgens das aufstehen und sagen heute
heute werde ich ein ganz neuer mensch
heute werde ich so richtig und ich werde
mich um andere kümmern und nicht immer
noch denken werde sportler haben und es
wäre total fit sein und mein leben
genießen jeden boxen neu entscheiden
ach ja jetzt eigentlich sonst zeigen
wollte
ich war ja shoppen nicht nur süßigkeiten
sondern auch ich zeig euch mal verwarnt
also zuerst habe ich mir einen brocken
denn ich fand den total schön und jetzt
habe ich in gruiten wird ganz so rede
ich liebe ihn ich weiß nicht warum und
ich bin im haus griffen durch
waterboarding hat den test gemacht wird
es ich bin in gräfendorf
es liegt an meinem guten herzen und so
ich bin super mensch
okay was noch leute das habe ich dazu
bekommen zusammen so genannt hast du
nicht gekauft habt harry potter and the
child und das ist das was das offizielle
buch für die piraten für das
theaterstück was ich zeige ich mir zeit
nicht bohnert weil der hashtag ist
nämlich kippe skript und ich möchte dass
sie kritiken
[Musik]
hier sind menschen in dem theater na ja
doch dort kann man hier zeigen hier sind
hermine ron und harry vor einem regal
dann haben wir noch also direkt neben
und abo und david haye war sogar zehn
sekunden vom vom theater stück entfernt
passt super cool war weil man einfach
drüber laufen konnte musste eigentlich
mit jacke anziehen aber naja und ein
paar meter weiter gab den laden genau
und da habe ich noch postkarten gekauft
die von omniture diese regeln als wieder
das sagen hatte dollar cambridge es die
enkel zu der post auf hogwarts hey
industrie beutel getan hat committed to
be wild wings of love
das ist auf dem film musik aus dem film
eine film buch also dass das konnte man
beim die abos verkaufen
ich glaube es hat fünf punkte kassiert
hier bietet das theater das ist das
theater bavaria film ja
[Musik]
da gibt's ein bisschen hintergrundinfo
und wäre damit spielt und könnt ihr auch
alles nicht sehen denn das model country
spoilern abhängig schon das buch gelesen
also das drehbuch zum theaterstück wenn
ja dann rational in kommentaren
und ach ja doch mal wir noch unsere
anderen laptop wir waren ganz vielen job
also ich glaube wir waren in keinen
richtigen daten dadurch niemand gekauft
wo harry potter gesucht wird und dass
gibt 10.000 gallonen gibt's auf meinen
kopf und das gleiche motiv habe ich mir
noch als poster geholt werdet ihr
wahrscheinlich in einer meiner nächsten
videos an der wand
und was habe ich noch gekauft das ist
der beute den gab es zu dem buch zum
theaterstück eröffnen gold und ich werde
jemand stolz dich berliner straße eine
tüte von den sachen diese gekauft haben
erhalten nach dem treffen der patch
geholt was ich mir auf irgendwas braucht
man kann wunderschön und ein
kugelschreiber wohl bescheid draufsteht
superwichtig
ja das war's eigentlich vom ein shopping
waren aktivitäten ist aber auch echt
alles super teuer sondern muss man ja
sagen
also ich meine ich wohne auch in berlin
in der stadt aber in london
die order pack in die hollywood teuer
ich möchte jetzt auf jeden fall gaddafi
retten
und dann seht ihr wie großartig es ist
nämlich so eine gummi schlange und davon
kann man einfach so ableiten
[Musik]
können den ganzen tag auf jeden fall
cool das ist das uns daran leid ich muss
sehen diesen crunchy riegel zeigen
der hat nämlich hat mein so klingt das
gar nicht
schreien arbeit indem man das hier ist
so ein schoko keine ahnung wie sich das
auf das haben auf jeden fall ist der
total krümelig noch übergangsweise an
habt könnt ihr davon die schokolade ist
und euch die superbiker weiter sie ganz
vergessen habe und am ende auf eure post
irgendwohin wkb schokoladen zwecke das
ist mein leben
hier sind wir ganz locker flockig
trocken ja so kommen
[Musik]
ich weiß warum ich hier so hart auf
englische süßigkeiten als ob sie genau
mein geschmack treffen würden
als letzte während wir noch nie
berti bot bohnen in sämtlichen
geschmacksrichtungen die liebe schon mal
banane black pepper blaubeere profi
kenny flott cherry phänomen als im dreck
rohr schweiz nicht auf die schwarze 42
und schmalz graf april marshmallow
verfaulte team ohne seife tutti frutti
wormald ich weiß nicht was barmittel und
wort nennen
wir fanden das weiß man hier haben wir
kleine floh die fingerdicke schmeckt mir
süßigkeiten okay nehme man andere farbe
das weiße soll nach reife schmecken
gleiches sollte sollten
[Musik]
war so als ob man auch ein stück weit
herumkommen würde das die schmecken nur
so ähnlich dreck wie wollen sie bitte
direkt in eine bohne packen also den
geschmack von dreck
[Musik]
popliteratur schmecken als letztes
probieren wir dann mal die puppe bohne
[Musik]
okay leute darauf noch ein keks das ist
der original mps leute ich verstehe
schon für den 15
ich weiß nicht wie noch immer sprechen
wollte ich freue mich darauf lässt aus
gefallen hat war sehr lustig an das
abschneiden
das hat schon spaß gemacht und es 2016
waren richtung gutes jahr nicht so hart
auf das neue jahr
also das was jetzt kommt 2017 ist
wirklich glaube es wird gut
ich habe pläne keine ahnung ob ich
irgendwann davon verwirklicht wenn ich
meinen mann zu fliehen wurde dann
bestimmt ja aber mal gucken ich auf euch
gibt ein gut und wir sehen uns dann beim
nächsten video
vergesst nicht hier sind noch weitere
videos und ich wünsche euch eine tolle
woche von bewegen kann